avete la copertina uguale copertino
uguale colori e girato così quell'altro
è uguale uguali la locandina e la stessa
qualcun'altro rota sono uguali non sono
quale anche da lontano non possono sono
uguali sono uguali che la stessa non c'è
di fare è la stessa shark man statement
vada per sharm che vi devo dire
qualcuno di voi si ricorda skeletal man
quel film che ho recensito un sacco di
tempo fa ecco ai tempi non l'avevo detto
ma quel film è prodotto da una casa
chiamata nu image che ha prodotto una
serie di film come un unico filone
mutanti metamorphosis creature skeletal
mains deichmann shark me nei boschi
toben ma siccome non posso parlare di
tutti questi film in una botta sola
altrimenti mi viene un indigestione
ho scelto shark man filmone datato 2004
diretto da michael o blitz senza
indugiare oltre tuffiamoci insieme in
questo shark man il film inizia con due
piccioncini su una barca in mezzo
all'oceano
come sei arrivato qui per puro caso per
puro caso
così vi eravate persi dopo che un fumo
nero vi stava inseguendo
[Musica]
ed ecco il nostro titolo signore e
signori
era dal 1992 che non vedevo una scritta
in power point e suo figlio ha fatto nel
2004 e per dire
sapete cosa mi sono rotto gli zebedei di
questi presunti registi che vogliono
fare un film con una creatura
all'interno ma quando devono fare vedere
una scena d'azione o comunque un attacco
da parte della suddetta creatura non ti
fanno capire niente
che cazzo lo fai a fare allora se
potessi mi butterei all'inferno
anzi perché non ne creiamo noi un
inferno fatto solo per i film osceni
come primo girone per i registi da
quattro soldi dovranno leccare le
budella dei cervi morti investiti in
tangenziale per l'eternità
wow abbiamo appena iniziati e mi sono
già praticamente [ __ ] il cervello si
prospetta un filmone subito dopo vediamo
degli scienziati intenti a fare
esperimenti brutti e cattivi
ma se metti la mano in una tanica
contenente una creatura aggressiva
rischi di perdere le dita i misteri
della scienza
ma passiamo ad uno dei protagonisti la
signorina ormai troppo vecchia per
portare quel taglio di capelli taylor e
la chiamo taylor perché è proprio la
taylor di beautiful e io lo so perché
perché lo so come lavora per una nota
casa farmaceutica il suo capo la chiama
per informarla di una scoperta
importante che cosa intendi per mistero
delle staminali sono cellule che non
hanno particolare corto
l'obiettivo e usarle per scopi curativi
ad esempio per sostituire le cellule
danneggiate da un attacco cardiaco e
perché tutte le case farmaceutiche hanno
una piscina nella struttura e un
solarium e donne in costumi sta venendo
voglia di fare un master in medicina lo
so perché
intanto nel laboratorio di prima
continuano gli esperimenti sulle persone
volete sapere che razza di sperimenti
prego la forza superiore di uno squalo
martello accoppiata all'intelletto di un
uomo un pesce marte un pesce martello ed
il coro universo mentale vorresti mai
unire un uomo come un pesce martello
muore mai come che mi lascia basito
iniettano europa ad una povera donna e
la sbattono dentro una serra per venire
poi mangiata da una creatura ignota
ma invece di farci vedere qualche sito
della mento che ne so io
passiamo a vedere quale altra
incredibile avventura ci aspetta
all'aeroporto dove taylor e il suo
collega arrivano nessuno vede che mi
serve aiuto
non male come premio di consolazione
ciao sono tom rete non ho ancora avuto
il piacere
ciao vorresti portarla per me e ti sei
meritata il mio primo ed ultimo stampo
da b a c
congratulazioni essenziale che io trovi
un soggetto con cui si accoppi
volontariamente la sua prole sarà
l'inizio di una nuova specie
le potenzialità sono enormi immagina
avrebbero l'incredibile capacità di
nuotare sott'acqua
lo possiamo fare anche adesso ap se
voleva farlo che è allora che cazzo stai
facendo non lo so ma si deve sbrigare
perché dopo dobbiamo unire gli umani con
i termosifoni per avere la capacità di
creare acqua calda segnale certo quindi
tutti i medici si dirigono verso il
dottor voglio conquistare i sette mari
alla sua casa al mare vuole fargli fare
un tour della serva e invitarli a cena
quegli aggeggi e funzionano male se vuoi
dietro un occhiata dopo cena
o mi correggo li fa stare seduti per ore
inutilmente e lo sto scherzando passano
dal giorno alla notte semplicemente
parlando sedute a un tavolo ma va anche
un mazzo di carte per fare due prisco le
ma la vera riunione inizia dopo quando
il prof
gli spiega di come gli squali abbiano
una minore probabilità di essere affetti
da cancro e di essere riuscito a curare
suo figlio
così ho incrociato staminali di squalo
con cellule somatiche e umane una volta
stabilizzata la struttura molecolare in
due settimane il cancro scomparve
completamente
[Musica]
gli offro il futuro atene razza umana
il futuro dell'umanità essere
trasformati in creature in computer
grafica
oh mio dio son finite davvero un uomo
pesce in sigi hai neanche prendersi la
briga di creare un costume in gommapiuma
stile power ranger sedevano sin
volutamente trash almeno impegnati così
sto pugno negli occhi ma il dottore non
li ha portati lì solo per quello li
vuole uccidere tutti fateci uscire
[Musica]
no basta così grazie mille e stato guai
è stato un piacere grazie mille ma no
grazie
grazie mille
lo sai quanto è difficile non sai quanto
è difficile guardare una scena del
genere dove un soldato lascia cadere
completamente a caso il mito mentre esce
dalla porta solo perché la trama le
aveva bisogno essi infatti subito dopo
usano per scappare dalla stanza
attraverso la ventola è certo mica
potevano troppo intelligente per farli
scappare ovvio e gulati diamogli subito
mosca deboli l'oscar per la miglior
scena forzata mai fatto soltanto per far
mandare avanti la trama grazie mario
solo tu riesci a capirmi quando parlo di
queste cose
grazie siamo avanti
iamm avanti mentre fuggono nella foresta
arrivano i primi gravissimi problemi di
quando sei in seguito dallo street
sharks poi andare a casa
odio e la cosa che mi fa più star male e
che non è neanche questa la scena
peggiore
la volontà della mamma
se tu in una situazione di pericolo in
cui devi scappare lo fai con dei tacchi
da 10 centimetri mentre sei in una
foresta e ti lamenti del vestito che si
sporca devi morire voglio che ti salvi
che riesce a ricominciare a vivere
ti trovi un ottimo lavoro ben pagato un
marito che ti ama due splendidi figli è
una casa enorme voglio proprio che la
tua vita sia perfetta è in quel momento
che spero che lo squalo teese modelli
davanti alla tua famiglia perdendo tutto
quello che hai di più caro
mi sa che devo iniziare a prendere
qualche appuntamento dallo psicologo
poco più in là raggiungono un molo con
attraccata una barca ma è piena di
guardia del professore armate fino ai
denti
faremo un tentativo voi dove venite con
me daje qual è il piano secondo voi come
fareste per espugnare a mani nude una
barca con degli uomini armati fino ai
denti come esattamente ti giri e te ne
torni da dove sei venuto perché non vuoi
farlo ma no è ovvio che poi che cazzo di
te basta semplicemente nuotare verso la
barca senza che nessuno ti veda
ovviamente salire e da salirla guarda è
così semplice a volte abbiamo bisogno di
aiuto che vuole accederci io posso
pagarla molto più di king sto per dire
una cosa che non dicevo dagli inizi
degli anni 90 ma quella il capitan
findus mamme
merluzzo migliore pieno di forza nei
bastoncini no alla dovuta duccio un
povero capitan findus
[Musica]
scusate noi dobbiamo sparare alla barca
giusto non a quelli che sono sopra ma
alla base della barca mero ok lo era
solo per saperlo grazie
proprio un bel piano complimenti ma
mentre scappano paul si vi ricordo che
lo squalo si chiama paul si chiama paolo
lo squalo li attacca strappando la gamba
d'uno amelia ragione dobbiamo restare
insieme più e julie non torneremo al
laboratorio cercheremo una dura per
riuscire a prendere segnale non
divideteli non dividetevi non dividetevi
non d io rimango qui con voi però sempre
una merda film cioè scusa devi per forza
usare tutti i cliché dei film horror
sulla faccia della terra così che è si
dividono fa un gruppo torna al
laboratorio da dove sono arrivati
geniale mentre il vecchio la
smandrappata cercano di far funzionare
una radio no no le scarpe e rovinate
ti prego basta se in una situazione di
pericolo cerca di pensare alla vita
piuttosto che alle scarpe abbi pietà di
chi sta guardando il film ti prego
scopriamo intanto che paolo può
camminare e sopravvivere sulla
terraferma
non ho niente da dire su questo anzi
sono contento che abbia delle abilità
particolari per uccidere sti cazzo di
protagonisti
ciao
ci sarà un cambiamento è tutto è tutto a
posto non lo è radici che si muovono
cosa cosa perché mi devo sforzare di
dare un senso a tutto ciò perché non
posso guardare un film trash e
rilassarmi una volta tanto è tutto a
posto
il suo vestito non servendo mi assento
un secondino torno subito
[Musica]
molto meglio come se non bastasse arriva
un elicottero militare che tenta di
farli esplodere
o la tipa rimane da sola nella foresta
ferita e la ragazza muore e la ragazza
muore
gli altri dopo aver ucciso la guardia e
rubato le armi
continuano il viaggio e raggiungono
laboratorio cosa stai facendo
sembra che la creatura via problemi con
la z il vecchio ancora vivo purtroppo
viene catturato dalle guardie costi
colpi si passa a farmi vedere effetti
speciali di a quattro soldi così
all'improvviso il vecchio scappa
nuovamente questa volta con l'auto
riesce a raggiungere gli altri
protagonisti di un senatore che cazzo
succede mentre sbatteva le palpebre si è
dimenticato di riaprirla ad un certo
punto si è schiantato contro l'albero
senza un motivo logico e c'è gente che
ha sceneggiato una cosa del genere
ok lui ruba l'auto poi hosting noi
andiamo a mangiare a mcdonald vuoi
venire
no grazie devo finire qui guarda che
hanno fatto tornare i big testi si
schianta contro l'albero io col becco e
aspettate perché il peggio deve ancora
arrivare
una dottoressa che si è ribellata al
dottor lo squalo martello li raggiunge
ma si porta dietro un elicottero che
dopo avergli sparato dei missili sparato
con dei mitra e fatto esplodere l'auto
sono ancora tutti vivi tutti
sospensione dell'incredulità un paio di
angurie chi è che ha scritto sta roba
jason statham
ho grandissimo sviluppo del personaggio
dottoressa nel affezionato a lei in quei
cinque secondi che l'ho vista rimasti
ormai in tre taylor il vecchio e il
terzo di cui non mi ricordo il nome
perché non me ne frega nulla si fanno
largo tra le guardie
una di queste riesce a catturare paolo
ea riportarlo al dottor ciò la fissa per
i pesci in passato non sarebbe stato in
grado di farlo si è evoluto altre tre
barche piene zeppe di militari cercano
di far fuori i nostri eroi che però
riescono a tenergli testa è certo
call of duty style
ed hanno iniziato soltanto a scaldarsi
che ne dite di attaccare una piccola
base militare e far esplodere tutto
sopravvivere ad un secondo attacco a
base di missili e mentre tutti sparano
rubare un elicottero
non vi basta ancora
allora facciamo gli abbattere
l'elicottero militare da solo a colpi di
ak47 e farlo esplodere
guardate qui non viene nemmeno scalfito
dai colpi neanche il figlio illegittimo
trascorse negher e stallone riuscirebbe
ad essere così tanto figo
mi sbagliavo sul loro conto sono
veramente incredibili fateli diventare
eroi nazionali hergé testato in loro
onore
mandateli nel futuro per fermare la
ribellione delle macchine santo cielo
che protagonisti stupendi e tutto grazie
ad una sceneggiatura che lo sta né in
cielo né in terra
grazie signor sceneggiatore senza
talento sei riuscita a creare un
capolavoro tra loro che tentano di
scappare in elicottero e il professore
che in possesso di paolo come finirà
questa magica avventura
[Musica]
l'elicottero esplode vengono catturati
in mano ma che tristezza dopo tutto il
casino che hanno fatto che il vecchio
vengono portati per la 150esima volta
del laboratorio dove sono sottoposti a
degli esperimenti un po birichini
l'altro invece sempre grazie ad una
sceneggiatura che ha più buchi del
braccio di jared leto il requiem for a
dream
non si sa come si salva raggiungendo la
barca raccoglie una fiocina e va a
salvare gli altri il dottor solo pazzo
perché mi picchiavano da piccolo va
avanti con l'esperimento vuole usare
taylor come cavia e darla in pasto allo
squalo
ma non ha fatto i conti con il signor
paolo
[Applauso]
come gran finale di questo polpettone
trash arriva al nostro supereroe con una
tanica piena di azoto spara in bocca
paolo e tanti saluti
non posso lasciartelo fare mia gara ma
il dottore ancora vivo
scherzavo distruggono il laboratorio e
succede una cosa che non vedevo da anni
su per esclusione al rallentatore senza
neanche girarsi e guardare
[Musica]
purtroppo il tuo vestito non si avvita e
quindi questo era sharman la recensione
è esattamente quello che ho provato io
guardandolo all'inizio non mi piaceva
per niente però poi mi sono lasciato
trasportare dalle tre sciume e alla fine
bianche divertito spero che la
recensione vi sia piaciuta e ci vediamo
con un prossimo video
[Musica]